All right. Good morning everyone.
Hello.
I love all the green. Thanks for showing
up everyone. Thank you to our families,
our staff,
our neighbors, and Superintendent Segura
for being here today.
Um your presence speaks to the strength
of this community and the deep care we
share for our school and for our
children's learning.
As an authorized IB World School, we
believe in inquiry, reflection, and
principled action. We encourage our
students to ask thoughtful questions, to
consider multiple perspectives, and to
stand up for what they believe is right,
even when the conversations are complex.
Today's meeting gives our community an
opportunity to do the same, to listen,
to engage, and to share our experiences
as part of an open, honest dialogue
about the future of our school.
Today we have 90 minutes set aside for
this meeting. Um I will now turn it over
to Ali Geraduchi um to review the agenda
and meeting norms, if that has not
happened. Okay.
Good morning, everyone. And before I get
started, I just want to make a quick
announcement about the availability of
interpretation.
Good morning. I'm Vic. I'm one of your
interpreters today. So, I'm going to
make a quick announcement in Spanish in
case there's anybody that would be
interested in having interpretation into
Spanish.
Thank you so much. And if we don't have
anyone in person, we are, just so
everyone knows, recording this in
English and Spanish. So, when we do get
to Q&A, we want to make sure everyone's
speaking into the mic so that everything
is captured, okay?
Um if we can go to the next slide, or do
you have the clicker, Rachel? Sorry. Or
do I have the clicker?
I have the clicker. So sorry. There we
go.
Um so, we are, like I said, I'm going to
go over the meeting norms and purpose.
Um we'll intro- go ahead and introduce
who we have here um to answer any
questions that y'all might have. Um and
then from there, you know, we had
planned to do an overview of kind of
what's on the table um from that initial
October 3rd proposal, as well as a new
option that was discussed for the first
time last night at the board meeting. Um
so, we can kind of talk through the that
alternative and what the the tradeoffs
might be if we were to consider that
direction. Um and then we um we have
pulled some questions from the comment
card that came up frequently, and so
we've prepared those. Um but I know that
we're going to have a facilitator that's
going to kind of go over questions. So,
we can either kind of go back and forth,
or if you already have questions, we're
really flexible on how we manage that.
Um so, for our meeting norms, I just
want to remind everyone what we're here
to do is to build the future together.
We want to acknowledge the challenges of
our current situation, while focusing on
ideas and solutions that make our
district stronger, more equitable, and
sustainable for years to come. Um we
want to try and honor time. So, we're
hoping that when we do get to the Q&A,
if people can make an effort to kind of
re- keep their um questions around a
minute, that we can make maximum time
for as many speakers as possible. And we
will try to do the same with our
responses. Um but we're not that great
at it. So, if you need to remind us, um
we're going to try to honor the process.
So, just um sticking with the agenda um
to stay on track. Um we want to honor
intent and impact. So, we know that
there may be things that we are not
going to agree on, but we hope that we
can all um go with the assumption that
everyone is here for the same reason, is
that we have a shared goal of having
strong, equitable schools for all of our
students. Um we want to honor space and
voice. So, we do ask if you do speak one
time, we'd like to make sure that we
make sure that anyone else who hasn't
spoken gets that opportunity before we
go back to the same person. Um we'd like
to try and stay solution-oriented, so
focusing on ideas, solution, and
understanding. And we are here um to
embrace transparency and empathy. We
recognize how difficult these
conversations are. Um and we want to
meet them with compassion, clarity, and
honesty. So, if there's any time where
maybe we answer a question of yours and
maybe you don't feel like we fully
answered what you were asking, it's okay
to kind of ask for follow-up to make
sure we get that clarity for y'all.
All right.
And did Oh, sorry. Did you want us to go
through the scenarios real quick, or how
do you want to Um
5 10 minutes and we can do that. I know
what we can go over the prepared
questions. Okay, perfect. So, then we're
going to go ahead and go through run
through what is proposed, and I'm going
to let our um
before we Oops.
I'm sorry. I meant to I didn't go over
the purpose, but essentially, we want to
make sure that we are responding to all
the questions that were submitted via
comment card, as well as any follow-up
questions y'all may have. Um our aim is
just to get a gain gained shared
understanding of what are the proposed
changes and the rationale behind them,
as well as this new option that we're
talking about, or any other ideas that
you want us to discuss. Um and then
really our goal is to gain insights that
could inform potential refinements to
the draft before the November 20th board
vote. Um and so, I'm going to turn it
over to our superintendent to kind of
give some opening remarks around the why
before we briefly go over the scenarios
on the table and then get to the Q&A.
Thank you, Ali. Um
just uh thank you to the Becker Woods
community for um kind of showing up the
way that you do. Uh this is precisely
what we want in Austin ISD. We want
families and communities that advocate
for their school.
Uh I can tell you in my experience here,
living here, growing up here, being a
product of Austin ISD, I've been in
places where community or
families don't show up. Uh and and that
that's hard. And so, what it
demonstrates is just your love for
public education, your love for your
schools and your students. And
uh if you're here, I'm going to be here.
I will always be here to engage with
you, learn, improve, refine.
I also want to acknowledge this is a
really tough spot. Um
I I want to acknowledge the pain, the
disruption that this has caused in your
families' lives, in your students'
lives. It's not lost on me. Um you know,
we are one large community. Uh there are
lots of things happening in Austin ISD.
Uh so, I just wanted you to know that
that it's hard. Um it really is hard.
And just appreciate y'all showing up and
and having this conversation with me.
So, how we got here, uh I think it's
worth having a conversation, a brief
conversation, cuz I I know I want you to
know kind of all the things that kind of
played into what we're trying to do as
an organization.
Since I've come on board, one of the
things that I've realized is that this
organization, AISD, has gotten to where
we are where we're not providing what we
need to every student within Austin ISD,
the over 70,000 students, because of a
series of decisions that have been made
over the last 144 years. I mean, that's
the honest truth.
Uh and when we think about where we want
to go as an organization and and kind of
my role at this moment, it's really
about how do we address the things that
are in our bones that have led to
inequities in our school system. How do
we break practices um that move students
away from AISD opposed to into Austin
ISD?
And for us as a school district, what I
tell people is we have to make sure that
every student gets what they need,
period.
And the honest truth is, right now, I
don't have the ability to do it. I just
don't.
Um we are an inch deep and a mile wide
when it comes to resources.
I'm not going to get into the history.
Y'all know it. Y'all Y'all know the
pressures that we have, either at the
federal level or at the state level, the
lack of funding, um the disruptions that
we've experienced over the last couple
years. I mean, these are things that we
are having to navigate and make
real-time decisions on, and it's
impacting lives in this in our
community.
And so, as you move forward, we
I I talk about strong neighborhood
schools, and I want to be really clear,
like Becker Woods is a strong
neighborhood school. There's no doubt.
Um and when we talk about strong
neighborhood schools, you see it when
you walk the the classrooms. I mean,
it's not about students that can pass a
test. It's about students who love
learning.
That's That's what we want. We want
students who feel comfortable in their
own skin. We want students who view
being bilingual as a as a superpower.
Like, these are the things we want for
our students. We want them to advocate
for themselves. There's There's
attitudes that we want. And if we do it
our way, we can protect how we do it.
So, at this moment, as we think about
trying to get to a place where we do
have strong neighborhood schools
throughout Austin ISD, we know right now
that that doesn't exist. There are parts
of Austin that simply don't have the
resources because we as a district for
decades have failed to provide them.
And so, this plan attempts to address
much of this all at once. And that's
where the complexity comes in.
So, I'm going to just kind of lay out a
couple things because I I I want you to
know where we were coming from when this
plan developed.
First and foremost, you know, we really
wanted to consider and get to a place
where we had aligned feeder patterns in
Austin ISD.
Uh there's a reason why you can go to
Merkeson and see students that have a
Trojan hat on for Anderson, or go to O.
Henry and see students that have a
maroon shirt on for Austin High. That's
what you want. Keep community together,
have them move through the feeder
pattern, you know, programs align,
friends stay together. That does not
happen in everywhere in Austin ISD.
We have middle schools that go to four
and five high schools.
Think about the disruption that creates
in our community. So, that was one of
the things we tried to accomplish with
this comprehensive plan. The second
thing we wanted to address was
this reality that our transfer policies,
the way that they've been built out and
kind of continue to uh operate within
our system, have led to movement within
our organization that is just not um
supporting our values
and so we're tackling that. Some of it
has to do with how we manage internally
our operationalizing of the transfer
policies and some of it's the policies
themselves. So we're we're taking and
refining those and you'll see those in
the plans.
The third thing that we're really trying
to address was the cost of operating a
large system.
We have 116 schools in Austin ISD right
now and we have a little over 70,000
students.
In 1996, we had about 73,000 students
and 96 schools.
And so as the city has grown, we grew in
parts of Austin, Northwest, Southwest,
Southeast, you know where those areas
are. In other parts of area Austin,
there is gentrification, affordability
challenges that our families experience
and we've seen families move.
And I'll tell you because I hear this
all the time, well charters have had a
role in that, they've taken well I will
tell you that our position in the public
education space has largely remained
stable.
There are lots of school districts, you
know,
different entities you know, trying to
compete for students but we have been
able to kind of hold our position but
the total number of students that live
in Austin, the birth rates, the housing,
all these things have put pressure on us
and we just have fewer students. That's
just the honest truth.
And so we tried to address that through
boundary changes and consolidations,
right? To where we could get to a place
where we had a lower lower number of
facilities that we could operate and
maintain because that's the same budget
that we use for compensation and
programming.
The other thing that we attempted to do
in this plan is to align
programs in Austin ISD to ensure they're
sustainable. We talk about wall-to-wall
dual language, you know, and and we in
Austin ISD lean into dual dual language.
There are school districts all around us
who are leaning out of dual language.
And so the programs are intended to
support emerging bilingual students.
That's the focus but we saw year over
year a downward trend in those students
in those programs. Instead of provide
access, we need to move those programs
to where they are. And I would say
lastly, we had to be mindful of the
turnaround plans and the accountability
risks that's been shifted into our feet
for the last many years.
In 2022, we had what seven 13 I think
it's 13 B schools that then turn into F
schools in 2023. Same students, same
teachers.
Right, think about that. You have a
school who was a B in 22 who's now an F
the next year.
And so when you think about where we are
as an organization, we have to address
that. We have to be responsive to it
because if we're not, then we get to a
place where we could potentially lose
control of our ability to educate our
students our way.
And you can see just our sister school
district north in North Texas going
through it right now.
And so this is a complex plan, there are
lots in it. I know we're here and we're
going to talk about Bryker Woods and how
we got to this specific solution
in the plan. It is a draft plan, things
will refine. This conversation is very
helpful. I promise you.
So I just wanted to share all that and
then hand it over because we do have
questions but I really want to y'all to
create the space to us to have answer
the questions. So thank you for the time
and I look forward to the dialogue.
Thank you so much. Do you want to take
this mic? Okay.
Thank you Superintendent Segarra. Can I
call you Matias or should we go You
should only call me Okay, okay. Just
wanted to get the lay of the land. Um
Thank you guys. This is such a great
turnout. This shows
just what a strong passionate community
that we have. It it honestly brings
tears to my eyes to see everyone out
there cheering and chanting and singing.
Before we get into the questions with
Matias, I did you know, we we are
finally getting to have a collective
voice for the community but we also
wanted to have a voice for the local
businesses that this will impact. So
Lindsey Hannah, a community member is
going to come up. She's been doing some
great work with our local businesses and
she's just going to say a few words
about about that.
Hi.
Good morning. Thank you thank you for
being here Matias. That's I'm sorry
that's really hard for me to just say
Matias but I will.
Okay.
Thank you all for being here.
I am wearing a Bryker Woods hat. I've
worn a lot of hats at Bryker Woods. I've
worn a parent hat for 12 years and next
year would be my lucky 13
for my our last
our last panther goes in fourth grade
this year. But
we are all
you know, taking different parts on
about this this issue and one of the
things I felt like was
really really important to display was
just how
rooted
this school is in the neighborhood and
the surrounding business community. I I
myself am a
small business owner in the community. I
live in Bryker Woods and my office is in
Rosedale.
Also a community that goes to Bryker
Woods
and so my uh
thought is that we really need them to
be represented. We will significantly
change and impact
not just this little pocket of
of Austin but beyond if the school
ceases to exist.
Um
the reimagining of it, I can't even
think of what it might be.
And that you know, these businesses,
there's a little kind of group of small
counselors that are across the street.
They each have individual offices right
there. There's a dermatologist office,
Wells Fargo. I didn't talk to them yet
but I will.
But
I you know, these are this is a list of
businesses including Kirby Lane who you
heard through from Mason Ayers earlier
who came to Bryker Woods as a student.
Like every time I talk to one of these
businesses, they had
just another story that almost like made
me cry every time. Like I don't need
your stories too. Like I can't collect
them all. It's it's hard. It's really
really crazy how connected this school
is to Austin.
And I
am just you know, happy to have
them as as partners in this
and supporters
and this list keeps growing every day.
This is literally like something that I
started two weeks ago
and we you know,
our resources are thin so I still have
to work and Halloween's coming. We got
to make the costumes. So anyway,
I just wanted yeah, the businesses are
are you know, here with us. We're
partnering with them and
they've given us a lot and we also we
frequent their you know, we we are their
livelihood too. We are parents, we are
alumni, you know, all all right within
this little little zone. So thank you.
Thank you for being here.
Okay, so
just for some introductions, my name is
Melissa Brown. I'm a parent here. I
think this is my ninth year at Bryker
Woods. I
I associate my identity to this school
to be honest. So I'm happy to be up here
to moderate. I'm here with Rob Henze. He
has two children. One is in fourth grade
here and one is now at O. Henry. And
then our to round out our advocacy
group, Jennifer Robertson is president
of our PTA. She's been
fighting hard for us as well and then
Teal Pennebaker who just spoke at the
rally. She's been a driving force for us
as well. So we are here to represent the
community and we're going to be asking
questions on behalf of the community. We
have pulled our neighborhood
association, we've pulled
internally the parents and we've really
tried to aggregate it down to some
really clear concise questions that you
know, we we just really love to get some
answers on. So I'm just going to kick it
off with the first kind of high-level
question. You just spoke really well on
the systemic issues that
AISD's been facing. I think the whole
community has a ton of empathy for you
in the position that you're in with the
threat of TEA and the turnaround
schools. I mean that is just not an easy
thing to tackle.
And so we support fully your plans
around all the the turnaround
situations.
In terms of closures though,
everyone in our community is very
confused why
Bryker Woods would be on this list. We
are high performing. We have a specialty
program in the in the IB that has been
data proven to only help enrollment for
the district going forward. We have land
to expand.
We are our enrollment is growing.
We are a staple. It's a true
neighborhood school like you mentioned
like I know that you value that and we
really are a true neighborhood school
that brings a community together. We
host church, we host all that. So
because of all that and knowing the
systemic situation that you're facing,
why Bryker Woods?
So I'll start and then hand over to to
Rachel or Dr. French.
Um so
when we started this process because I'm
going to start with the second question.
You said high performing. There is no
doubt that Bryker Woods is high
performing. When we started this
process, we wanted to be really clear
that we weren't going to use
accountability to drive the
decision-making process because if we
did that, then you'd only be closing DNF
schools. Right? And you think about,
well
what did we as a school district not
provide to those schools that led to
those outcomes?
Right? We as a school district are
you know,
producing the outcomes
because of who we are.
And so that's why it didn't drive. It
wasn't it wasn't you know, this school's
an A, this school's a B, this school's a
C, we're going to go in that order. It
was really based on the
process that we developed, pulling the
data
and for us as an organization when you
think about the number of seats we have
open in Austin ISD, it's well over
20,000 seats. Right? So much larger than
the Moody Theater. That's how many seats
we have open.
And they're not all, you know, in
necessarily available to where you can
make simple decisions and just
consolidate. It doesn't really work that
way. You have lots of areas in Austin
where you're 75% utilized or 85%
utilized and that difference multiplied
by 116 is really what gets you the
25,000, 24,000 plus seats.
And so when we look at areas of Austin,
we look truly at areas. It's not a
specific school and say this school has
this many seats, they can fit here. What
we say is in this part of town, given
the geographic area, and I would say in
this geographic area, I would use West
would be the end of our attendance
boundary as a school district, to the
south would be the river, uh to the
east, you know, not quite all the way to
MoPac and Airport, but probably a little
bit, you know, shy of that. And then to
the north to south of 183. That's kind
of the area that we're looking at. And
we say, "Okay, collectively between all
these schools, we look at how many
families that live in that area."
Because what we know is that transfers
come and go. Uh we've seen huge
increases in transfer rates and then
huge declines in in transfer rates. And
so if we build out our plan on transfer
rates and a principal leaves or program
changes, we see huge fluctuation in
enrollment based on kind of the culture
and climate of the school, right? You
have a great combination here, but I've
seen and what we know is that in years
past, if something changes, there can be
an exodus and because the students don't
live in the area, enrollment begins to
drop.
And so we really focus on where our
students live and where our buildings
are. Those are kind of fixed.
And then we look at an entire area and
say based on the available
the number of buildings that we have,
the capacity of those buildings, we do
not include portables in those
calculations and I'm going to tell you
why.
The reason we don't include them is
because right now we have over 600 of
them. Well, we had over 600 of them in
2017, representing 1.3 million square
feet.
That, when you think about the most
expensive space to operate and maintain,
it's a portable. It's exposed to the air
in really all sides and they're meant to
be temporary solutions. In some cases in
Austin, they've ended up becoming
permanent solutions. We have portable
Our newest portable is like 30 years
old. Uh we have some that are 70 to 80
years old.
And so moving forward, if we kind of use
um transfers and the number of transfers
plus the available capacity in
portables, you're essentially not
considering 5, 10, 15 years because
these portables, the transfer rates,
those are things that can vary and
change quickly over time.
So, the reason Bryker Woods ultimately
got on the draft plan was because of the
number of available seats and the
movement between the schools,
recognizing that there are schools that
have capacity that are larger.
Uh when you think about the age of those
schools and what they can essentially
absorb, we needed to figure out how to,
you know, identify the number of seats
to pull out and there's not a lot that
Bryker Woods could absorb, but moving
the other way, it could be done. And so
that was it was an iterative process. We
looked at lots of other schools in the
area. Um it wasn't that we identified
one school and started there. It was
truly kind of movement amongst the
schools. Uh and that's how we arrived at
the current draft plan.
Um I Is there anything I mean, that's
that's precisely how it occurred. Uh we
have other areas of town. I will tell
you not that it I want you to know that
there are other areas of town. I would
argue that Sanchez, Zavala, um Govalle,
and Ortega are kind of in a similar
situation where there are just a surplus
of seats, over 2,000 seats that are
surplus. And whatever you do with one
school impacts the other school and
they're different elements. One's
historic and so
that that is the process we go through.
Uh we get feedback, we refine, we
adjust, but right now, um
the it's really a function of what can
be moved where, knowing that we just
don't have schools that are 40% utilized
in the area. We have lots of schools
that have 70%, 25 65% and so on and so
forth.
Um but I I was going to be I don't want
to take all the time.
>> No, no, it's all good. Thank you so much
for that. Um we're we we have six
questions. As Melissa mentioned, we've
talked to you all through through
polling, we've talked to the community
around us. We have six questions that we
shared with Matias yesterday evening, uh
so that everything I'm sure you perhaps
didn't have a chance to review them, but
it shouldn't be surprising questions.
And the first question that I wanted to
focus on is is to dig a bit more into
your comments around enrollment and
capacity.
Um we've conducted our own survey of
families coming into Bryker Woods and
have confirmed with the developers
building high-density housing nearby,
including The Grove, the new housing
coming in in Rosedale, the Rosedale
school site, and townhomes on Medical
Parkway, just around the corner from me
in Rosedale,
that this will have a huge impact on
future enrollment, impact that we
haven't see reflected in the data.
Additionally, we've heard from families
and staff at Casis and Matthews that
they do not have adequate capacity to
accommodate our students. It seems that
future projected growth and limited
capacity at other campuses could pose a
challenge for meeting coming enrollment
needs in this part of Austin. However,
the good news is that as recently as
2018-2019,
Bryker Woods effectively accommodated a
student population of 425 students. From
where we sit, growth is coming. We are
well-positioned to receive that growth.
Can you explain where growth from future
housing developments and tight
enrollment of schools in our area shows
up in the plan and the kinds of
conversations the district is having
around this incoming growth?
Yeah.
Uh great question. So,
uh when we
when we work with our demographer, um
and and our demographer looks at
uh obviously census data um and and
there's a lot that goes into that, but
we look at projections. One of the
things they do do is they go and have
conversations with developers with the
City of Austin's Department of
Development, the DAC, and just talk
about what what projects are in queue,
what projects are in development. And
that does supplement our analysis. The
question becomes is what's the going to
use a term that probably doesn't sound
very welcoming or loving, but it's it's
kind of student yield is what I would
say. Um it is if you have these types of
units or these types of um multi-family
um mixes, how many students would you
expect to see out of those developments?
If you have a three-bedroom apartment
complex, you're going to see a higher
number of students per unit. If you have
a whole bunch of studios, you will
obviously see something much less. That
information is very well documented. We
use that, we have it. Um I think right
now, uh and we've committed to going
back. We've already done it once, but
we'll go back again and communicate kind
of what we believe what we're seeing as
what we've been told the yield is. Um
you know, we're happy to to look at it
again and make adjustments. Uh I think
the projections I mean, I'll hand it
over to Dr. French as far as the number
from that specific development. I've
heard The Grove, I've heard a couple
others. I guess my question is have you
spoke We've spoken to the developers.
Have you spoken to those developers as a
part of this process? So, our I the
super me as a superintendent have not.
Um but the the demographer has. Um now,
if there are specific developers, like
what we can do is share with you who
we've met with, you can share with me
who you're meeting with, bring that
together. I I I want to make sure we
have an accurate understanding of what
is going to come. I want to also be
clear that there are lots of things that
people say are coming that don't come,
right? And you see that, we see that.
So, we just have to be really honest
about what data we're going to use in
our model, assumption-wise. Um if it's
too far out, it's 5 years out, they
don't have entitlements, it's not zoned,
I mean, that's not something we could
really rely on. Uh if it's progress,
it's capitalized, you know, and we have
the permits to move forward or it's near
that, then you can probably count on
that. And then we have to agree on to
what the yield will be. And that's
really a conversation based on uh with
the developer. So, uh we're happy to do
that. I don't know, Rachel, if you want
to add anything to it, but I will commit
to that. And I I need you all to oversee
it. Great. Yeah, just to add and I'm
sure many of you have already seen it.
Our demographic report on the website
does outline the specific units that are
included and it also has a chart of
specific developments that are not
included because there there's just not
enough information yet for our
demographers to actually put a number on
it. Um there is one that
what how many would it be if that does
come to fruition. And so that is baked
in, understood in our proposal. And I
will also say that we redo our
demographic projections annually. We are
also building into this every two or
three years, we will be doing a review
of our boundaries. And
so we're not doing this drastic, painful
thing again. It needs to be as a
district, we need to do our due
diligence of making small adjustments as
these developments come on board. And we
are confident that in the surrounding
schools, there will be space for
students. And so if developments do come
to pass, we will plan ahead for them
when they become more real and we can
make more um realistic projections. And
we might move boundaries in a few years
as we need to, but we do have space in
the schools in this area to support that
influx. Um something our demographer has
also kind of shared with us that they're
seeing throughout other urban districts
and cities that they work with is that
often times the birth rate decline is so
much that all these new developments
don't outweigh it. So, even though you
do see a lot more units, we're still
just there's still just less kids.
I I last night at the at the meeting, it
was met suggested that the demographer
is is on your point making projections,
but not that these conversations are
actually happening. Can you confirm that
what you've done to date are pure
projections based on historical data or
that you're actually speaking to the
people that are building these things?
The medical the medical is is gaining
feet by the day, right? The Rosedale
project is out of the gates. The Grove
is is very clearly planned and being
built. So, th- those feel like very
tangible numbers we can get our hands on
if the right conversations are happening
and not just focusing on historical
projections. Yeah, our partners visited
Austin in the spring and they drove the
city, they met with demographers, they
met with developers. I cannot and I will
ask them as uh Matthias alluded to like
we will confirm which specific
demographers they had a conversation
with, sorry. Developers. I have no idea
what word I said. Um
So, we we can confirm that cuz I can't
speak to like who did you talk to, but
they were boots on the ground for
multiple days in the spring driving our
city. So, they have done their due
diligence as much as they could at the
time. But, we will
>> we're good. And the fact that Matthias
said that he would he would move forward
that I trust that. So, all right, let's
move on to the data. Um
or lack thereof or the integrity around
the data. Um our community spent a great
deal of time getting familiar with the
data rubric. We We were consistently
confused by the description of our
building's capacity which factored in
programs and classroom types we don't
have like pre-K 3 early childhood
classrooms and a maker space.
Um they also for by our account
miscalculated the count of the um
general education classrooms. Um and the
quality of the building we uh determined
that that was also inaccurate. Um it
makes more sense to us uh to understand
our building's capacity based on current
usage. Again, many of us have experience
with this campus serving over 400
students. When my oldest daughter was
here, we had 400 students and it was
perfectly fine. Could you explain to us
where your where our current usage
should look different or why programs we
don't have should be factored into our
capacity?
Yeah, so I'll start um and then hand it
off to Rachel.
Uh some of this is tied to um
the portable comment that I made
earlier. That's just that's the honest
truth, right? So, Bryker Woods, uh
Barton Hills, there are certain
portables that have been placed and have
kind of just grown to be part of the
school.
Um but, they're also in the Barger Creek
watershed. Uh there there are lots of
things that that kind of keep us from
being able to count them as permanent
infrastructure for the next 30 40 50
years.
Now, um if there was a significant
increase in capacity by some of the
means, it part of the permanent
structure, then that we would be able to
count that. But, across the board uh we
made a a decision years ago to not
include portables because we were
actively actually trying to reduce the
number of portables. What I'll tell you
is that throughout the district there
are schools that are underutilized to a
pretty significant degree and have five
or six portables, but they're still
filled. And I get arguments that
Matthias like that we're using our
portables. Well, yes because you have
the space.
Um but, they're are very very costly.
And so, that's one thing. So, I think if
you know, we can talk about your current
operational capacity as you use
portables, how we
>> was around data integrity, not around
the portables. We I think we understand
>> Yeah, okay. So, so data integrity, let's
talk about that. Um so, one of the
things that
that we did is we um identified what was
the square footage required to to ident
to communicate that a space was actually
conducive
a general education classroom, right? In
years past you could have a square a
square footage of 400 square feet
allocated and then because a principal
or someone deemed that a classroom, that
was a classroom. Well, the reality is
that there are certain configurations
and sizes that we want in our school
system and even So, what we did is we we
said, "Okay, each of these spaces within
the permanent building are identified as
a classroom. We allocate 22 students um
per classroom and then we look at the
number of um kind of services that are
being provided to students who receive
special education services. And then we
say, "Okay, based on the student
population, this two to teacher ratio in
these classrooms is going to go down." I
think we Is it eight to one or 10 to
one?
10 to one. And so, that drives down,
right, your utilization because instead
of going 22 to one in the classroom, you
know, we are wanting to ensure that the
students receiving special education
services have designated space in the
building. So, that end up being a 10 to
one. I'd like you to focus on the
specific elements of the question
including things like classroom
miscounts, programs we don't have
negatively impacting our score, and
putting us in position through a rubric
process that set us up to be where we
are today.
I want to remind everyone what the
rubric is and what it isn't. The rubric
is data on our permanent buildings, how
full they are, how empty they are. And
we use the exact same methodology for
every single school in the district. All
our schools use space differently.
Some of them are saying, "We can't fit
this many kids in our building. Are you
crazy?" Others are saying the opposite,
same as y'all like we can fit way more
kids. And that is true because we
operate buildings based on programs.
But, for us in this effort we had to
look at programs can change and how we
use space can change. So, we had to have
a standard baseline.
And so, for every single school we look
we have a floor plan. We looked at which
rooms are above 600 square feet that
could maybe be a classroom. And we count
that. If there are schools that have
maker spaces and I at the time was told
y'all had a maker space in your
building, so we did count that.
If it's in a portable, we would take
that out. And if we did that, sure it
would change your score slightly on the
rubric. I I that is true. If you didn't
have your maker space. So, that is one
nuance and the reason we do that is
because we are trying to do more maker
spaces. The reason we include spaces
that maybe y'all don't have is because
we want to have them everywhere. So, if
we're at a baseline of like what we want
in an elementary in Austin ISD to have,
that is what we use. So, there's a a
certain number of pre-K 3 spaces and a
certain number of sped special education
spaces that we account for across the
board because in an ideal world we would
have those and they wouldn't be on a
portable. And so, there are some
campuses that they can only have life
skills in a portable because of
accessible restrooms, we still counted a
classroom in the building to serve that
population because that is what really
gives us an apples to apples baseline
about just the building. So, then what
we do and what we worked through after
the rubric was actually diving into the
reality of the situation. How are spaces
really being used? We still don't want
to use portables long-term, but we do
look at programs. We do look at like,
"Okay, what is the reality?" And this
comes into play in terms of especially
if we're we have schools that are going
to receive students. We've had We're
making boundary adjustments um that
you'll see on Friday because when we
dive deeper into the actual programs
being offered and that we want to still
do them, it actually can't fit the same
number as the rubric. And we knew that
going in. The rubric was meant to be a
standard way of looking at things and
knowing Yeah, I I understand it's it's
very nitty-gritty. I think the punchline
that our community sees is that it was a
choice to not include portables in your
assessment at the parish of a
community school like this. That was a
choice that you guys made. And And my
daughter work is going to school in in a
portable right now and she loves it. She
says it's so cozy. So, like it's a
choice, you know? And And And now we're
suffering because of it. But, we'll go
on.
I'd like to focus on
Thank you.
Obviously, cost and financials are an
important part of this process. Um we
know that closing campuses comes with
real financial costs, especially those
of insuring dark buildings and
enrollment declined when families choose
to leave the district rather than go to
their newly reassigned schools.
A team of parent data scientists within
this community
ran the numbers and found that with an
assumption of a 20% student attrition
rate, closing Bryker Woods would cost
the district $470,000
in the first year alone. We've had the
chance to put the report in front of two
different Texas school finance experts
with decades of experience as CFOs and
consultants and they found the report to
be solid.
Cuz Tiana's one of our data scientists.
She'll She'll go ahead but I'll finish
the question.
We know that finding efficiencies a pri
is a priority for the district right
now, but our community is having a hard
time understanding how closing Bryker
Woods contributes to an effort when it's
unclear that it will actually save the
district money.
Could you reflect on this? And I think
my very importantly, could our community
see your cost-benefit analysis uh to
justify this closure?
Yeah, so one of the things that we're
doing um
and and this is where I I gets
difficult because we are looking at the
whole. Um I mean, that's that's the
honest truth. It's 116 buildings,
billion dollar budget. You know, it it
is they're not pockets of available
seats everywhere that can just be
collapsed easily. And so, when we think
about building our budget um and looking
at our total reduction in costs, what we
do is understand, okay, if a school gets
um consolidated into another school,
you're going to have a reduction in
administrative costs, right? A principal
salary, staff salary. And these are the
things that are just honestly part of a
cost of running a school. Right? We're
87% of our budget is staff.
And so, when you take those those costs
to run a school and distribute them over
the number of students, then what you
quickly find is that the um kind of
efficiency of getting to a larger campus
coupled with the opportunities, not that
that's not happening here, but in other
areas of town, you kind of have to get
to that critical student population to
have a full-time, you know, uh PE or um
you know, fine arts um person allocated.
When you get to really really small
small student populations, we don't
quite have that. Lots of times local
communities supplement, right? We know
that happens where the the PTA will will
come in and provide the resources and
that really helps. That helps us
tremendously. So, back to the budget
analysis.
Um there I recognize that there um is
going to be a loss potentially um with
the disruption of this campus. But, I
mean, that's the honest truth. Um now,
as far as campus to campus,
you know, we estimate the total cost of
a move and in a reduction, you know,
it's going to be over a million dollars.
So, you
that that's
that's one of 116.
Right? So, we're going to show the
details campus by campus. We're looking
at the whole um you know, we believe
right now conservatively it's over $24
million.
The one thing that comes up all the time
is Matias, you're going to end up
spending $800,000 on the turnaround
plans or you're going to spend $800,000
on these um plans to ensure that we
don't introduce any takeover risk. The
problem is we're going to spend those
dollars anyway.
Right? Like like we have to break that
risk, period, if we're going to keep
control of our school district. Um the
board has asked for additional details.
Our CFO is working through them. In the
first when the first draft of the
document, we kept it pretty high level
in summary form, but we are going to
show on the 29th and 31st um campus by
campus. But we again look at the whole
uh not each individually. So, but yes,
20% is the assumption um at the basic
student allotment, then there's there
would be that loss. Our hope is that
they don't don't leave, but I understand
that that is a
like a potential
potential of loss. Okay. And and we'd be
happy to follow up with you directly to
walk through in more detail the
assessment that we that Cassandra did
and that we had verified by outside
sources.
>> that's different than the number I heard
yesterday.
That we talked we'll talk about it
later. Okay.
Um all right, let's talk about the land
that we sit on. I mentioned earlier um
you know, we have a ton of land here. We
have plenty of room to expand. So, if
we're looking at a 50-year vision for
AISD, this
>> be considered like an optimal
opportunity to build on. Um so, the
question is if you move forward with
closing Breaker, what would your plans
be for the land? We're quite concerned
that a sale isn't doable given deed
restrictions and the fact that our
school sits in a flood zone.
Yeah. Um we also have concerns about the
plans for the nearby Rosedale school
turning into luxury apartments. Can you
explain what your plans are for our land
in the event of a closure? Yeah. So, um
the luxury apartment piece, do you want
to talk about both parts of it because
since you mentioned the Rosedale side as
well?
>> Sure.
Okay. Um so, this is something that I I
hear a lot. I heard it yesterday
multiple times. Matias, why don't you
just go sell, you know, all the land and
and make up the budget deficit?
Um that it's it's doesn't work that way.
Uh for those of you that that understand
transacting a piece of property,
especially a public piece of property,
you're looking at 18 months at the
earliest. Right? By the time you get
through entitlements, you find a partner
who can capitalize it especially based
on highest and best use. Right now with
the multi-family pressure that we're
seeing in the market, um it's you're not
seeing kind of those huge like payouts,
right? Um but we go through a process
with community.
Uh we do not ever start with a real
estate value or what we're going to do
um at any point in this process. That
has never come up at any point. What we
talk about is, you know, what is our our
approach if we move forward and
determine that a piece of property is to
be repurposed. Um I'll tell you that
what we would do is kind of lean into
what we've done and then build on it
based on community need. Uh so, in 2019
um the board in the last vote that they
had identified different elements they
want the administration to explore,
really focusing on community benefit.
Community benefit was identified at that
time as teacher housing, workforce
housing, community space, open space, uh
those sorts of things. And so, uh those
obviously with this board's input would
kind of derive the overall approach. We
as a school district would then work
with the community and say, "Okay, what
works in this community?" But I will be
really honest, there are some
communities that say, "We want nothing.
Just leave it
like ground, you know, make it a park."
Well, that that's hard because, you
know, ideally we'd want to you know,
monetize it if we could. Um it doesn't
necessarily mean a fee simple
transaction, uh but we do take community
input, we make adjustments. One of the
things I'll tell you is Pease Elementary
School uh was a school that um had been
closed and we heard from the community,
"Keep it active with kids." We heard
that over and over and over again. And
so, we worked with Congressman Doggett's
office, they provided funds, and then we
actually were able to ink a deal with
United Way, and now it's an early
childhood center. Uh in other parts of
town, we had um
an Anita Coy uh site. Uh we worked with
our community and it was teacher it was
housing, teacher housing. And so, right
now we moved that property into the
public facilities corporation and now
it's 600 units. So, we would go through
a process with the Breaker Woods
community. We wouldn't our trustees
expect it, I expect it, our council
expects it. That's what we would do. We
would not uh move forward introduce
something um without y'all's input. Um
as far as shuttering goes, I get that
question a lot. Um
you know, we would we would not uh we
would still activate the site. Um you
know, we would go through a process, we
would not um we would still secure it,
we would still make sure that it's
accessible to the community, we would
still make sure that it um you know, we
operate and maintain it, uh but it
obviously wouldn't have the same cost
because it's not, you know, loaded um
and operating as a school. But that's
what we would do and we have evidence of
us doing it uh and and we would do that
here.
Chase, do you want to explain Rosedale
and how
I I don't think they want to talk about
Rosedale.
Yeah, we're we're good.
Yeah. Yeah. W- one thing that I cuz I
didn't have the microphone that I I just
wanted to say going back to our
financials question, would love for you
to make a commitment to our community to
look at our analysis and and take the
time to look at what we've put together
and how it can impact cost. But I'd like
to move on to a question on something
you've already mentioned. I'm sorry, go
ahead, please. But I was going to say I
don't think I've gotten that last
analysis. The one that the one from last
night. The 20 per you said that it was
con- We're happy to share it with you.
Absolutely.
Yes. Just to be Um I'd like to go to
another really important topic that
you've already talked about today and
and we share your concern about it,
which is the threat of TEA takeover. Um
we've heard from several trustees that
they must vote on this plan because of
the TEA TAP plan deadline, but they
would like to have more time.
We understand that the TEA TAP TIP plans
will require some consolidation and
school closures, but for the cool
schools where that is not the case,
especially where it's unclear that
closing the campus will save the
district money, why do we need to
consolidate? Please explain why we can't
focus on the looming TEA takeover
situation and address consolidation and
school closure needs at a different
time.
Yeah, great question. So, um
what I will say is um
Austin ISD has a bad habit of not making
hard decisions.
That's the honest truth.
Uh going back decades and decades and
decades, there's evidence that the
district did not take decision make
decisions that they probably should
have.
And so, I do not want to be the
superintendent who just continues to
delay and delay and not have a hard
decision. I mean, whatever decisions are
in our district whether it's TEA or
special education or downsizing central
office, like we're going to do it to
protect our overall school district. Um
now, you know, you're right. The one
that the consolidations or the plans
that are directly tied to the November
20th um approval are those that are tied
to the turnaround plans. I will say,
however, that there are lots of things
tied to those. An example of that, if
you look at the plan, well, there are
some turnaround plans that are directly
tied to a um program move. And the
reason that's done that way is cuz we're
trying to address two kind of challenges
at the same time. So, though the first
this first school has a turnaround risk
and the second school doesn't, the
second school actually allows us to
create a new opportunity where otherwise
we'd have to shutter a school. So, um
they they could um you could have
separate timelines. What I do not want
to do is to avoid a difficult
conversation. Um consolidations,
boundary changes, these things are hard.
They take they they take lots of energy
and resources within our system. Uh for
the last four years, I feel like all
we've been doing is is is like fighting
tooth and nail to keep us moving. The
TEA agreed order in 2023, special
education, that was the thing that was
going to take us over. Uh y'all remember
that? It was horrible. We worked really
really hard. That cost us money. Then
you move from there and try to balance
um you know, enrollment and you have to
get staff into our schools. At one point
we were, you know, 76%
um staff. Now we're 97% staff. Attrition
rate's going in the right direction. We
were 22% attrition rates of of staff at
title one at title one schools. Now
we're less than one and a half, 2%. So,
all these things have been taking so
much time and energy from our system.
And you know, I I the a trustee a couple
trustees last night asked about timing
uh and they asked me to consider it. I'm
hearing that from the community. Uh it
is something that we're going to look
at. I just don't have an answer can tell
you right now that it's this or this. Um
but last night it was asked of me to to
look into that. But I also don't want to
um
avoid
you know, a real decision um regarding
how
you know, kind of where we are from a
budget perspective. That that's to me is
the hard talk.
>> I think that's understandable and I
think from my perspective, because I did
speak to TEA cuz I'm curious from their
perspective of what's going on in AISD
and they said the only interference they
will come in on are three things:
illegal activity by the district,
special education um out of compliance,
and um and the turnaround. And so,
finances have nothing to do with that.
And so, I think our community is saying
this feels rushed. We you know, because
of the the finances that we've
uncovered, because of the data wasn't
correct, like we just need more time to
to get with you to to to show you that
this does not make sense.
Yeah, so so
um
So, the one thing I would say is uh
I I can appreciate that comment from the
agency because of the how they're
currently engaged with us now.
Um because we have a TEA agreed order or
special education, of course, that's the
first entry point. Because we're
required right now to provide turnaround
plans, that would be the second entry
point. Um I don't want anybody to leave
here and think that financial risk isn't
a real risk. Uh failing your first
rating or introducing um financial risk
is a very quick reason that an agency
will intervene. It's one of the reasons
that unfortunately Fort Worth is kind of
being brought in maybe perhaps quicker
than they were. And so I I understand
why they said that. We are in
conversations with the agency to make
sure that everything we produce is in
alignment and will be accepted
ultimately, but I don't want anybody to
leave here thinking that that is not a
real risk. It maybe it's not the same
level because of how we've been able to
manage it thus far, but it quickly can
shift. Um, and that's what we
desperately want to avoid.
>> Okay, we can move on. Thank you. Um,
last question and then we're going to
turn it out to you guys. Um, last night
we I think a lot of us watched the
uh, the board meeting that you had. Um,
there was some discussion around
potentially Breaker Woods being a
receiver school for other schools that
are going to be closed down and need to
find a new home. Um,
you know, we would welcome them with
open arms.
And so
I
I know it's premature. I know it just
came up last night at the meeting, but
we would love to hear your perspective
on it and um, and you know, how you
could see that playing out.
Yeah, so this is um, so you're up there
with me. We all stay tonight and watch
the board meeting Yes. or the work
session on Saturday maybe from 9:00 to
4:00. Um, there's lots of things going
on. Uh, so what I want to be honest
about is we we look at all of it. Like
we we as an idea comes from the
community, um, we do test it. We do
explore it. Um, we we there have been
things that we received that have
changed our our draft plan and you're
going to see that on the 31st that there
are things that we've heard that yeah,
we're changing that. Um, we're making
lots of changes in transfer policies,
making changes in some boundaries that
we know can be accommodated based on the
the modeling or the ideas that we
received. Uh, I did hear that um, from
from some from a trustee from some
trustees um, as a as a consideration.
Uh, that's going to require some work.
Um, you know, I don't yet understand
precisely you know, kind of cuz we have
I mean last night kind of ended and then
we ended up you know, do some meetings
this morning and then here. So we
haven't had a chance to kind of regroup.
>> Yeah. Um,
I want to find solutions that move the
system. It was never about any specific
school. I really want our community to
know that that's not who I am, that's
not who we are. It was really truly
about figuring out how to become more
efficient to identify the resources
needed to support the entire school
system. And unfortunately there are
geographic boundaries that kind of limit
how far you can look in an area. Um, but
yeah, I mean that's if there if there
are ideas that you have that y'all test
and are and
you know, you know are not
so abstract, you know, then then we we
will do the due due diligence and as we
progress that if it begins to to evolve,
you better believe I'm going to talk to
our trustees about it, but it has to
kind of be in alignment with our overall
goals, our vision of the of the overall
effort.
>> Yeah, and I
and I I'm so happy to hear that have
spoken to a lot of the trustees and they
have expressed that they are supportive
of that type of
um, that type of situation. So really
really excited to hear that you are open
to it and that you're you know, really
being thoughtful about what to do with
Breaker Woods specifically. Um, so um,
with that um, we are going to open it up
to um, questions from the audience.
Emily, um, Emily is one of our transfer
um, moms. So I think Yeah.
Hello.
Sorry, I think everybody in this room is
tired of hearing from me. Uh,
and you probably too. I So I I do want
to be really clear. Everybody knows I'm
a transfer family. Matthias spent time
in our community on Tuesday night,
right? In the East side.
Um, and so I I have to say you've
clearly been staying up very long
nights. You spent the time and so I want
to start off saying thank you very much
because obviously
Yeah.
So as an East Austin transfer District
1, hello again. Um,
Yeah, so I
Again, yeah, I was the first one to
speak. Um,
So I think today you talked about right
in terms of the the transfers
specifically for Breaker Woods say that
we can't rely necessarily on that, those
can come and go. And I I understand that
because that plays into what you're
trying to fix on the East side in terms
of why some families are leaving to go
to other schools. I would challenge
though that the story here at Breaker
Woods for why transfer families are here
is a little bit different in terms of
why our families chose this school
versus trying to flee a school from
there cuz to be frank, I was looking at
the schools all within my area
to go to and those seem just as viable.
We chose this and a lot of us choose
this specifically because of where it's
located. Um, there is a there is a huge
central core here where people work. Um,
you're still going to have transfers out
of neighborhood schools regardless and
hopefully you'll mitigate that, but I
really want to challenge the assertion
that in specific to this location from
an AIC perspective, you are better
served from having a school here where
you have employers all around. So
there's there's a vast majority. We've
pulled all of our all of our transfer
families here in terms of where they
work and that was the main determinant
as to why they chose Breaker Woods. So I
obviously I always do this. I don't give
a question, I give a statement. Um, but
I I would like to challenge that in
terms of when you're re-looking at this
and you're looking at birth rates and
density populations etc. And yes, you
want to keep people in your area.
Breaker Woods transfers are a little bit
different than someone fleeing and say I
want to gentrify East Austin and move my
child to West Austin. That's not exactly
what the scenario is as to why the
transfer families are here. So I just
want to say that.
I was sending my stuff alone up here.
I'm I'm back.
Uh, no, I I you know, I I don't know if
that requires a a response. I I will say
that um,
Colleen. Uh,
not because I don't think that it is
deserving of a response. It's just that
it that is an important point. Um, and I
don't necessarily disagree. People
transfer for different reasons. Um, you
know, and to your point you at the East
side community that we had conversation,
that's one of the things that we as a
district have not done well is is kind
of managed transfers, but I also
recognize that I do not want to sever an
opportunity for a student who doesn't
have whose family is making a decision
to go to a different school for
different reasons. Especially if that
school for whatever reason has kind of a
scarlet letter from the school to from
the state, right? Cuz my my job my my
job is to make sure that all of our
schools thrive and the color of your
skin doesn't impact the outcomes that
you have, right? That that that's my
job. And we're moving the system and
it's going to get there, but at same
time I understand where we are now and
getting to where we need to be is going
to take some time. I appreciate your
comment. It's a very good comment. I I
would like to understand more. I am
aware of it. I'm curious to see kind of
what percent of the transfers are
actually tied to that specific component
versus just a transfer, but that I
appreciate you sharing that. I can look
into that.
>> Thank you. Um, all right, we're going to
take a question from one of our
superstar teachers, Colleen Fairbrother,
fifth grade.
OH, Y'ALL STAND. SORRY.
HI, UH,
MR. Segarra or Matthias, sorry. Um,
Sorry, it's so anyways. Okay. Um, I'm
Colleen Fairbrother. We met earlier. Um,
so like you, um, something we have in
common, I went through AISD.
Um, my mom taught at AISD
for a while. Um, and then
uh, Doss Marcus and Anderson, go
Trojans. Um,
sister, brother went there. My dad went
to Anderson. So like we rolled deep. So
I say this, I'm not someone that usually
speaks up and out loud. It's very just
not my thing. I
the opportunity
um, that IBP provides
for our kids is so vital and I think
there's some misinformation respectfully
that's been out there about it. I myself
was an IB student thing. Um, what it
does for our kids, um, I've taught at
Oak Springs and I've taught here at
Breaker Woods. Um, it teaches our kids
how to think. And so when I was at
Anderson, I literally honestly at the
age of 15 learned how to think. We do
something called thinking routines, it's
from Project Zero. Um, and it just helps
organize our kids in their thinking and
synthesizing um, to be globally minded
citizens. I've taught first through
fifth grade. So I am a huge proponent of
early intervention in tandem, meaning
academic wise and also socially. And
this program, it starts at pre-K. Um,
if we can have early intervention of
cultivating and molding globally minded
citizens, I mean the effect on the world
that that would have.
I mean, I have children talking about
perspective. I have children talking
about and understanding the ways in
which other people live. I mean, the
things that it could do and from an
another perspective, a branding
opportunity. Our 371 followers on our
Breaker Woods Instagram, it can only go
so far, you know what I'm saying? And I
I just implore you to realize what a
branding opportunity on the district
scale if it was more so
advertised about IB, us being the only
IB PYP campus in the district. Um, I
think that would could be really
powerful and what a branding opportunity
and a moment for our district to
honestly make some money. Like to be
honest. Um,
but the program is just
it's so It's just the things it does.
And just on a personal note, too, our
principal, Alicia Hill, like
single-handedly
She's going to be so uncomfortable, but
No, this is so important. I've been at
Breaker Woods since 2020.
She's my third principal.
Single-handedly
resurrected this campus brick by brick
in so many ways. Bringing that program
here, revitalizing, making this a campus
that people want to go to, work at, and
be.
And I just really think she deserves
Hiding, probably.
Um
I just and I'll stop talking, but I
implore this team to understand the
vital nature of the International
Baccalaureate program, really, and what
it could do if we just magnified it as
also a branding opportunity. It just
creates wonderful citizens that Because
at Breaker Woods, we don't prepare them
for the next grade. We prepare our kids
for life. That's what we do. So, thank
you.
If I just could say one thing to build
on that, you talked about sharing ideas.
We've been sharing ideas since the
beginning of the school year, and then
one of the very first things we shared
with you and the trustees and your team
was an idea that we worked with Colleen
and the teachers, with Alicia on, of
really consciously scaling the IB
program through an IB center of
excellence based right at this school.
Um And and the data shows that it does
help with enrollment, and the district
has an enrollment problem. So,
do you have any thoughts on the IB and
how it doesn't travel if you guys close
the school? Yeah, well
Sorry. Uh so, first off, incredible. Uh
I got to spend time in your classroom. I
was very impressed and a very Even
though I only spent like 6 or 7 minutes
in that classroom, it was it was pretty
it was very impressive. Um thank you for
being with us as an Austin ISD alumni. I
actually have something I want to give
you before you leave. Um so,
what I'll say about uh
IB is that No, we we believe I mean, we
understand the value of it. I think that
one of the things uh that's been
challenging is how to ensure alignment
within our system so that students have
a continuous educational experience.
Right? That's This is kind of goes back
to the feeder pattern alignment problem
that we're trying to solve as part of
this.
Because years ago, we actually looked at
launching IB at Casis Elementary School.
Uh and this was kind of 2019, 2018 time
frame, and one of the reasons it didn't
make was because, well,
there wasn't a feeder school that Casis
would feed into or ultimately a high
school that would ensure program
continuity.
And and so, it was abandoned at the
time. There were lots of other reasons.
And then you fast forward, you know,
several years, and and now Breaker Woods
has been able to kind of launch it
successfully.
And it really takes like a partnership.
The community wants to be able to should
be able should want to do it. The staff
have to buy in, right? And you have to
have the resources to ensure that it's
viable. Uh you all were able to do it
with very little help, if any, from the
school district. I I'm aware of how it
came about. Um I I certainly am
interested in supporting programs and
building them. Uh I do want to make sure
that we do not trans strans Sorry. Yeah,
strans uh students like can and leave
them stranded, sorry, in um in a
vertical team. So, just just to that
point, we we have had real conversations
with O. Henry. Um our principals and the
past principal has discussed it, and
there is very much interest in
having a vertical for IB, and they and
they're interested in collaborating with
us on it. And we'd be interested in in
helping any Title 1 schools or anyone
that needs that help with enrollment and
to create this special program that
could really draw kids back into those
schools. We would help be a um you know,
a feeder or a
a school where we would provide that
training. Well, and that's the kind of
work that we should be doing.
So,
so, what what you've done and what you
all are doing and what um others in the
school district are doing are what we
should be spending our time on. That's
just the honest truth. Uh I mean, uh so,
well, so, let
So, I I don't
I mean, I I don't necessarily agree with
the that, but uh the challenge is we've
been dealing with huge disruption after
huge disruption after huge disruption
for the last 4 years. I desperately want
to get to a place where we're growing,
we're stable, we're thriving. I mean,
you had three super talk about three
super three principals. You had three
superintendents in 2 and 1/2 years.
Like, that is like catastrophic in many
ways. Um and so, I just want you to know
like I am desperately trying to get to a
place where I can be there with you in
building these systems up. Right now,
the risks that I'm navigating, like
honestly, to protect who we are is
consuming every almost every moment of
every day. Uh and so, I want to get
there with you. I I love what you're
doing. It's just, you know, creating the
time and the space to do it well. I do
not want to do anything poorly. That's
that's the kind of my big thing.
I No, that's I appreciate that.
Okay, Dr. Hill. We don't need a
continuum
in IB and at
Oh. I'm so sorry.
Uh we don't need a continuum for IB. Uh
the primary years program, it prepares
our students uh for education like no
matter where
we go. And did you read the letter that
my sweet principal sent you about um
the International Baccalaureate program
earlier this year?
It was about a month ago.
Oh, no, it was pretty recently. It was
about a month ago.
Okay, let's get to another question. Um
I let Do you want to
ask yours?
Um First of all, thank you very much for
being here. I don't know if you were
here in time to hear the kids saying
Breaker Woods forever. Um but one of the
strength of the school as a parent is
that we are safe and loved, and my kids
come back better adjusted every day.
One of the things I have missed from
AISD throughout this process is
any talk about the actual children.
Every educational expert will tell you
that school closure is disruptive and
has educational, financial, behavioral
consequences that go through college
and beyond.
I appreciate that in a complex
organization like this,
you can't keep the boat on a steady keel
the whole time,
but I would very much like to hear from
you what conversations you have had
about actual children, actual parents,
and how you plan to help those children
mitigate the enormous damage that
closing 13 schools will cause.
You sent some counselors after the
announcement came out. We have an
amazing counselor here, um
and that was just an announcement. So,
you know, I have two kiddos.
We're all doing this because we love our
kids. You love your kids. Um I just want
to know what the thought is about their
psychology, their development, how we
protect them.
So, uh I'll start and then I hand it off
to Stacia. Um she's leading much of this
work. So,
the
like students have to be centered in
everything that we do. Um right now,
because of what we're talking about, we
it can very quickly seem as though
they're not the center. Um and and I
want to acknowledge that. And And there
are lots of adult conversations
occurring, but when we think about um
how harm is introduced into a system and
what communities are impacted to a
greater degree, we have to think about
as a system, what do you families need?
What do we need in order to ensure that
we mitigate that disruption and that
harm as best we can.
The one thing that we know is that
thoughtful
plans
that include counseling support,
licensed mental health professionals,
resource deployment, resources to have
our parents communicate with their
student, all those things are very, very
important, and they can't be done in a
relatively short window or period of
time.
And so, that is one of the reasons why
whatever we do, um whether there's an
adjustment in time or if we vote, like
all these things, you're not going to
see me make decisions in the spring
semester. Like, I'm not going to do it.
Um so, the reason that we're doing is
we're going to have bridge teams that
are built up. Uh we're going to have
community voice, principal voice in it.
One of the things that I think is
frustrating for families right now is
that we're in this in-between moment
where, you know, if I I've taken steps
and say, "Hey, we're going to begin to
provide these resources." And they're
like, "No, no, no, well, you haven't
made a vote yet." And there've been
other instances where, you know, they're
beginning to already talk, and every
community's different. So, I'm really
trying to follow kind of have the
community take the lead. Um I'll have
Stacia kind of respond kind of directly
for to as far as the elements in the
plan and how we're approaching it, cuz
that's really under her um purview. But
I I want you to know we are very
like thoughtful and responsive to it,
but I also understand how it doesn't
feel like it's there yet. Um and I just
wanted to express to you kind of why it
it probably doesn't feel that way. Go,
Stacia.
Good morning. My name is Stacia Paschal,
and I serve as the director of strategic
planning and organizational
effectiveness. And you might be
thinking, "Well, what exactly does that
mean?"
That means that when we are thinking
about approaching work, how do we have a
human-centered design, and how do we put
systems in place to ensure that we've
got a thermostat on how the people in
the system are doing. And so, that is my
role. Um I serve with Dr. Lewis on what
we call the bridge team.
And the work of the bridge team, and if
you give me the space, I'd like to kind
of walk you through how we are
supporting the adults, the students in
the system.
With the bridge team, we are planning
for impact that's happening now and
impact that will happen post vote. That
looks like providing a toolkit for
campus leaders to utilize. That looks
like professional learning that's
happening monthly with counselors. That
also looks like professional learning
that's happening monthly with
principals. We are looking at what are
morning meeting lessons that could help
facilitate conversations. What are
one-pagers that we can send home with
caregivers and give to go to student
newsletters so parents can have
conversations because ideally for us
we don't want any student to attach
their identity to this process.
This is a challenging process. We as
adults have developed a bandwidth to
deal with a process like this, but our
goal is how do we ensure that our
students are separated from that?
Another way in which we are looking at
supporting students is ensuring that our
licensed mental health professionals are
part of this process as well as
counselors and restorative practices. So
there is work being done and as uh
Matias said, there are different ways in
which you'll see it and it really
depends on the level of involvement in
the campus administration and what they
deem is appropriate for their campus at
that time. Thank you so much. We
appreciate it. We're going to have two
more questions um and then we're going
to out of respect to time we're going to
see what Matias wants to do, but Teal,
do you want to go ahead? Yeah, so thank
you so much for coming. Um
I'm worried about kind of the overall
decrease in trust around AISD leadership
because of this process. It's felt at
times like I know that you all are
trying, you know, you're limited in
resources, you've hosted all these
calls, but we often haven't seen any of
our concerns reflected in updates to the
rubric or updates to the the draft plan
that came out.
I think there is a very real risk that
not just students leaving this campus,
but they're going to leave all of AISD
because of distrust in this overall
process. So I know that it sounds like
you're open to at least punting a little
bit on this so that you can get it
right. Could you talk a little bit more
about that and make a commitment to
really deeply considering not so rashly
closing 13 schools and really putting at
risk like sending AISD into an even
bigger existential crisis.
So um you said all 13. I'm there's I'm
not going to propose that. I I I I want
to be clear that as we were talking
about earlier many of these are tied to
turnaround plans.
Um so that's defined by the state
November 21st. We're going to spend all
day uploading our documents to the
agency, which means the vote has to
occur on the 20th. So I'll be really
clear. We lump everybody together,
that's not going to be something I'm
going to be able to support. That's just
the honest truth.
Um because of that that distinction.
Um when it comes to trust uh
I I hear you. I I I am someone who is
trying desperately to build a
trust-based culture. I have worked in an
organization, this organization in fact,
and it was a fear-based culture. I don't
know how many people remember what that
felt like. I've been here for 7 and 1/2
almost 8 years. I know precisely what
that felt like.
Um and so
I I am I do not want um our system to
all of a sudden feel as though
you know, we are not doing what we can
to support them. Uh and me being
present, me being transparent and
refining and improving the plan is part
of building that trust, but there have
been lots of have been doing over the
last 2 and 1/2 years that lots of
families haven't really seen, right? And
I think that's part of the challenge.
We've been working very very hard for
the last 2 and 1/2 3 years and what
ultimately happens sometimes is there
are 116 schools and each one of them has
their own ecosystem. And so before the
the thing that I I want to
lost my train of thought when you stood
up Uh because I was just going to say
something so I was like you can say it.
>> make sure we get to it.
Um but anyway, no so so as far as
committing to looking at timelines, the
board some board members yesterday asked
me to do that. I'm going to look at
that. Um I am not going to commit at
this point what it will or will not be,
um but yes, that that is what I'm going
to do. Well, because something you said
is really important. So you all have
been doing all this work for the past 2
and 1/2 years and we don't know about
it. So
why don't you buy yourself a little bit
more time and educate us on what you're
doing so that we can really believe in
what you're doing because we want to
ultimately believe in AISD and trust you
all and feel like you're acting with
good intentions and do this right is
what we're trying to say.
So
Okay. All right, Max.
Last but not least, sorry. Like were you
going to say something Matias? No? So
it's my turn. All right. Bryker Woods
forever, folks. Bryker Woods forever.
Good morning, Matias. Good morning to
the guest from the district, etc. Law
enforcement.
Good to see you. You are welcome to
Bryker Woods anytime. I am Max. I was
PTA person for eight years. All the
eight years I was here fundraising to
fix the bathrooms, to sponsor the IB
program, everything. And what I want to
say is that I was always
so
blown out of my mind by community
involvement at Bryker Woods. But it goes
beyond Bryker Woods. We had line items
in our budget for Zavala, $5,000.
We went there. We did stuff and
everything. And this showed me
that with community involvement so much
is possible.
The state of Texas is not going to be
there for you.
TEA is not going to be there for you.
But the community, if you get us
involved, as Teal said, 2 3 years you've
been doing this, you don't have to do it
alone.
We can be there with you. We can have a
seat at the table and collaborate with
you. We got data scientists. We got all
sorts of skill sets in this community
that can help it.
And I'll conclude with saying together
so much is possible.
But what I've been seeing from my side,
when you do a lot of the work
on your own and we're on the receiving
side
we see that you ask us to vote for
bonds. We voted for the bonds. You asked
us last year to vote
for a tax increase to address YOUR
DEFICIT GAP. THE VERY NEXT YEAR WE'RE
closing schools.
And we have a larger deficit. So from
our community perspective
we feel on the receiving end
and this could just continue.
So the ask I'll conclude with, do you
think it's possible not only to maybe
postpone decisions, but to get the
community involved? Bring us in. People
do this for free.
THEY WILL SHOW up cuz
I'll end with what you started with.
We're here cuz we care about the
district. We're here cuz we love public
education.
And this can be a force.
Matias, just so you know, that's
actually how he talks in real life. So
he wasn't yelling at you. He's like that
all the time?
I usually want to give him a microphone
cuz he just yells.
Say something.
Um
So I I know we're um
You're you're not you're not wrong. I
mean I I that's there there are other
individuals that that all like just like
this all over our school district. And
many of them are at schools that don't
have
you know, the same history that Bryker
Woods has.
Um
You know, and and I do not want to break
trust. And yes, I would never ever ask
from my own community, the community I
grew up in, to do something that I
>> hey, this is what we're changing and
then 2 days later tell a different
community. And so you will see in the
draft different changes around transfer
policies, sibling transfers we're
approving automatically across the
district.
Rising sixth and ninth graders we're
approving automatically.
You know, students that are transferring
into a school can transfer automatically
to any of the schools that that school
is being re-zoned to. So so we're making
lots of changes programmatically. We are
making lots of changes in boundaries.
So you'll see that, but I I want to
really thoughtful about how I release
information because if I don't do it in
a sequence way, as many of you all know,
it could it could send the wrong message
or confuse our community and I don't and
I don't want to do that. So that's the
point I wanted to make is why you
haven't seen a change from October 3rd.
I have over 7,000 comments. We've been
going through them. We've been dealing
with it. These These staff have been
working so hard.
So I appreciate your comments, sir.
I love the energy.
Come to our board meetings and hang out.
Keep me awake at night.
So thank you. I appreciate it very much.
>> So thank thank you. So just to wrap up,
I just
take have some, you know, follow-up
thoughts just to say that
you have a goldmine in this community,
truly. We are workers. We want to be
your ally. We want to be your partner.
We want you to think, if I need
something, Breaker Woods, let's go. And
we will be behind you. I promise you
that. And so we just need the chance. We
just need the chance.
And
I feel like I've I've gotten to know you
a little bit and I I I really do trust
you that you want to do the right thing.
And and if you give us the chance to be
your partner, we will not let you down.
We will make this the shining star of
AISD. I promise you that. So just give
us a chance. Thank you, Matias. Thank
you for coming here.
Thank you to our community. Thank you to
your staff.
Thank you. Thank you so much.